will tell us whether deeper is better
only when shallow is good thank you for
inviting me so this is basically a work
so as a motivation this is coming from a
blog by grass probably many of you
already saw it so but but let me in any
case so it's it's like a fake
interviewer that that ask someone to
print the numbers from 1 to 100 except
that if the number is divisible by 3
print fees if it's divisible by 5 print
buzz and if it's divisible by 15 print
face buds so it's a question in an
interview and then the guy say yeah sure
I know how to do it import pencil flow
and let's try to to build a network for
it and it goes on I urge you to go and
and read it because it's funny I think
at least I think it's funny at the end
he says I didn't get the job so I tried
actually running this and it turned out
it got some of the outputs wrong thank
you very much machine learning and they
think this is a true story about machine
learning it caught some of the outputs
wrong in general and then he ends with I
guess maybe I should have used a
different network all right so so a
basic question and this is what I'm
going to talk about in this talk is
depth efficiency the basic question on
which distributions deeper networks are
much better than shallow ones right and
there has been a lot of research on this
question and and there is a
[Music]
several examples of depth separation
basically saying that there exists some
functions which can be expressed by a
small network and small meaning that the
number of neurons in the network is say
polynomially large and not exponentially
large but must happen in exponential
weeds in order to be expressed by a
shallow Network and this means that we
need to go deeper in order to have an
overall polynomial size for the for the
network and there is results by Mateus
and endo hard and in some others that
wrote many such with such results and
what I'm going to show in this talk or I
will try to argue in this talk is that
if there is a strong depth separation
and I will explain exactly what do I
mean by strong depth separation but if
indeed you must have exponential size
for shallow network and only small size
for a deeper network then gradient based
algorithm will fail on the deep network
so in other words the such strong
separation between shallow and and deep
networks mean that it is not a very
useful example because graduate gradient
based algorithms will not be able to
successfully train a deep network on the
problem and in order to show this I will
talk about fractal distributions
fractals are very convenient for
studying deep networks because they have
many similarities to what's going on in
deep networks so I will show that some
fractal distributions can be expressed
by a deep network by small deep Network
but cannot be expressed by a small
shallow Network so there is depth
separation and they will allow us to
define a notion of approximation curve
meaning how much
is really needed in order to solve the
problem so we can we can ask about how
good a deeper and deeper network
expresses the problem and strong depth
separation means that there is the
approximation curve looks like flat and
then at the end it goes up okay and then
I will show that success of gradient
based algorithm depends on the shape of
the approximation curve and if there is
strong depth separation then these
algorithms are likely to fail so I will
show it on on one example and but there
is a bigger conjecture here and this is
only a conjecture that this is not just
for the examples that I will show but
this is actually what happens everywhere
in in deep learning so in order to enjoy
a deeper network when you use gradient
based algorithms shallow networks will
work as well and then at the end maybe
we'll talk about so why do we need
deeper networks it will work means that
you can train a shallow network and you
will find a solution which is not random
which is better than a random guess if
it's a classification well if it's if it
is a very very shallow yes but otherwise
now we do not have any strong results on
efficiency of all three but maybe maybe
I will say some words at the end that
this is another type of conjecture that
if if the approximation curve is nice
and if shallow gives you something then
maybe you can even train efficiently in
terms of computational power you can
maybe try an efficiently deeper networks
but this is another topic that I will
maybe say few words at the end but it's
not the topic of the so my running
example will be fractals
so in ifs or iterate iterated function
system is defined as follows we start
with a with the cube the D dimensional
cube minus 1 to 1 the interval to the
power of D this is K 0 this is this will
be the first set so it is depicted here
and then there are our functions F 1 to
F R and we apply each one of them on the
set so for example in in the example
here F 1 takes the rectangle here and
project it here okay and F 2 project
here F 3 here and therefore here okay so
we apply F 1 to F R on the previous set
in the fractal and then we repeat it
again and again okay so this gives us a
set they set at the end after three
iterations the set is all of these small
rectangles ok we make some assumptions
on the functions that they are affine
function invertible contractive and
their images are disjoint this is very
convenient for the analysis
the depths of the fractal is n is how
many times you repeat this operation and
the example here is 4 is a function the
4 function that just squeezed the
initial rectangle to the corners so this
is an iterated function system now what
is a fractional distribution the fractal
distribution is a distribution in which
positive examples are sampled from the
fractal set KN and negative examples are
sampled as are sampled from its
complement so if we go back to as an
example here so positive examples are
from here and negative examples are from
all the white areas and here are some
additional fractal set the contour set
sierpinski
so this will be our running example this
fractal distribution okay so what I'm
going to show at the beginning is that
these are very very convenient
structures for showing the depth
separation for showing that you need to
go deeper in order to express some
fractal distribution so the theory the
first theorem tells you the following if
we take an iterative fractional system
in d dimensions and there are generating
functions in depth n so the parameters
are D dimension are the number of
functions that generates a fractal and n
is the number of times we repeat the
process now we define any fractal
distribution DN over this set so forever
for any such fractal distribution there
exists a real feed-forward network of
depths 2n plus 1 and weeds five deep
times are which realizes the end
completely exactly so you can express a
fractal distribution with a deep network
and the depths of the network is order
of the depths of the fractal meaning
that you can get zero error threshold
function I didn't see who asked second
so there is a it's a threshold function
but all this works also if you require
separation with margin so you can have
margin and there are no examples in the
margin between the difference between
the negative and positive areas
it sounds from the description there's
only one function so say it again
even the parameters the end there is a
single function that classifies the name
it's not a family of functions like a
single budget so first if you you need
also to specify the function f 1 to F R
so it's a family of functions
so so I'm going to show the proof and
the reason I'm going to show the proof
is because it's very simple and I want
to show that fractals are very
convenient structures first I'm studying
depth separation so so let's let let's
see the proof the proof is by induction
which makes a lot of sense the basis is
to show that a shallow radio network can
approximate the indicator function for K
0 and K 0 is simply minus 1 to 1 ^ D
okay and and this is really easy because
value function can approximate a step
function so you need the step function
for every dimension and then sum them up
and you're done ok so now the induction
step suppose that we already have a deep
networks that expresses the set K n
minus 1 so it tells us 1 if we are on
the set and 0 otherwise
now we recall that the next set K n is a
union of the application of the our
functions F 1 to F R on the previous set
okay and if I we assume that there are
affine functions invertible and have
disjoint images ok so what does it mean
it means that if we take now some vector
X in K n in the set that we want now we
want to construct I of n which will be 1
if X is in K n so if we want to
construct such a function we take X in
kN then there must be some Z in K n
minus 1 and some index I such that X is
the application of F I on Z ok but since
fi is affine and invertible we can write
it as red equals to fi to the minus 1
applied on X ok so just taking the
difference between two values we get a
step function now what we have here what
we have here is
summing over everything in the image of
the inverse of F okay and this is an
affine operation because it's some fine
we can express some with a value
feed-forward function if I minus 1 X is
just an offering transformation so again
we can express this with a neural
network and I n minus 1 is the previous
network that we had so we just make it
deeper and now we are fine so by doing
affine transformation and value we can
now express the indicator function for
the next set and we are done with an
inductive proof ok so this shows that
and if you do some counting you see that
the number of neurons that we need is
small it's basically linear in the
product of phasor dimension and and the
number of so let's see if here I used it
yes because because you want you want to
apply it here ok this isn't the basis of
the induction so you all all the time in
the same set ok so this is one side of
the depth separation result that we say
deep network you can express the fractal
distribution now we need to show that
with a shallow network in order to
express the function the fractal we must
use an exponential depth and and here
the theorem says that if the
distribution has nonzero probability in
any area of of the fractal then says a
uniform distribution then a network of
depth T must have a width of at least
something like r2 n over TD
in order to realize the end it means
that you need the tea will grow within
otherwise you will need exponential wait
okay so we need you need that the depth
will be order of N and if it is a
constant or much smaller than n then you
have exponential growth of of the number
of of the weeds of the network in order
to express the fun so how do we prove
this result this is also a very simple
proof it's basically a counting argument
so on one hand a network of weeds K and
depth D has at most e K over d ^ TD
linear regions and this is this follows
from basic vc-dimension calculations on
the other hand in order to realize the
fractal distribution it is not hard to
see that there are R to the N linear
regions which are separated so you must
have more linear regions that you can
express than the ones that you need and
just by comparing the two you you get
the basic counting argument tells you
that in the shallow what network you
cannot express a fun the air that
complements KN is exponentially large
not necessarily not necessarily that
we're not talking about the volume okay
let's assume so any point in don't
contrived distribution
the you have na the area of the positive
examples is exponentially smaller in n
there in what sense in the sense of
volume volume is not an issue here the
issue here is because you put half of
the distribution on KN and half of the
distribution on the paper it's okay so
otherwise if you take uniformly over
everything then you arrived at that just
saying if zero every time would be
alright
so so we showed that we showed the
fractal distribution and we show the
deaths depth separation resolved for the
fractal distribution which is nice but
nothing is very new here it's just you
know if a nice a nice way to show yet
another example of that separation but
it's not interesting by itself the
reason is it is interesting is because
now we can go to to the main claim of of
this work that if you have strong this
depth separation then gradient based
algorithms will fail so we need one more
step and we need to explain what do we
mean by strong depth separation so so
now we will talk about approximation
curve and strong that separation so so
far we saw that the network of depths
order of n can express a depth in
fractal but if you use a shallower
network you required financial weeds to
fully realize the distribution okay but
maybe it is hard to fully realize the
distribution but it is not hard to
realize it to some extent so for this we
need to define the approximation curve
which tells us how much of the negative
examples are on the fine details of the
frontal or basically tells us what is
the performance the accuracy of using
using a set an indicator of set
the early stages of the fractal in order
to approximate the function so we define
P of J for an index J to be simply 1
minus is a loss the 0 1 loss average 0 0
1 loss of the function which simply
tells us to say positive on examples
from KJ and negative of examples of
outside of K J and J is between 1 and
the depths of the plateau so if we take
P of n we will get 1 because this is a
definition of a distribution over
fractal you must say positive inside the
KN and negative outside of the KN if you
take P of 0 it means that you just start
with with saying positive on everything
and we assume that the mass of negative
examples is exactly the mass of positive
examples of the error will be 1/2 so P
is monotonically increasing from 1/2 to
1 but the question is how it increases
from 1/2 to 1 and there are many ways to
increase from 1/2 to 1 but one one way
is to start very very close to 1/2 and
only at the end go to 1 and another way
is to gradually grows from 1/2 to 1 and
you see the two examples here so here
negative examples are distributed in
many many places and here negative
examples are distributed only on the
fine details of the fractal ok so the
question is do we put the mass on the
fine details of the fractal or also on
the course details of Sigma if we if we
put the mass also on the course details
of the of the fractal then the curve
grows gradually from 1/2 1 if we put all
the mass only on the fine details of the
fractals then we begin by 1/2
proximation which gives us nothing at
the beginning and only at the end
we goes up okay so we call this curbs
approximation curve of the fractal and
it it is a property of the distribution
so you can keep the same fractal in mind
only change the distribution over the
negative examples and get different
approximation curves so now what we
argue is that appropriate approximation
curve tells us something about strong
depth separation so what we say that if
we have a depth end distribution with
approximation curve P then roughly the
loss of using neural networks of depth T
where it is almost j order of j is
roughly 1 minus P J so it is bounded
from above by 1 minus P J and from below
by something which is very close to 1
and P object so basically P of J if you
recall we we defined it by one
particular function the indicator
function of K J but this theorem tells
you that roughly for every neural
network of depths order of J okay the
performance will be the same as the
indicator function so it will be like
the performance of of same indicator no
matter what network you will choose so
in other words P determines how well the
class of neural networks of depth T and
which K approximates the fractal
so what what we get from here we get
from here a strong depth separation when
do we when we have a strong depth
separation so if P of J we look like
here so it will be close to 1/2 a small
small values of J
then the loss will be roughly 1 minus
1/2 which is 1/2 basically random guess
for every neural network of depth T and
with gate so we cannot we cannot find a
neural network of depth D and with K
that does bet much better than a random
guess ok
on the other hand if the curve looks a
better then we know that there is a
neural network of depth roughly J and
small weeds that approximates
approximates the distribution according
to 100 PJ so we will do better than a
random guess so if the curve is like
this we have strong depth separation
because with a shallow Network we will
not be better than a random guess but
with a deep network
so now arguably the holy grail of depth
separation is to show stuff like this
and now we can we came to the punchline
of of this work is that if the
approximation curve looks like this and
we have strong depth separation then
it's very nice in terms of expressivity
but it is completely useful useless in
terms of what we gain what we really
gained from the depths because we will
not be able to train the deep network
using gradient descent okay so strong
depth separation if we have strong depth
separation that then gradient based
algorithms will think okay so in order
to show this we will focus on one
specific example it's a one dimensional
a contour fractal with fine distribution
so it is basically depicted here we
start with the interval 0 1 and then we
take one third and one third and a hole
in the in between and this will be c1
and then we keep doing it repeatedly in
order to build the set and and and we
will put all the negative examples
between positive examples so on the find
details of the distribution
okay so what we show we show that if you
take a depth D with scale network and
try to Train it with garden descent so
training with gradient descent usually
starts with initialization of the
weights of the network
so let's WB the weight of the network
and suppose we initialize them randomly
in the normal way by the normal way I
mean usually you initialize the weights
by something that is proportional to the
inner degree of a of the node that the
weights goes into it okay and you take
uniform or Gaussian based on how many
edges incoming edges will have to the
node so suppose that you do you do it
like this and then you take a depth and
one-dimensional contour fractal and take
some J which is not too small but is
strictly smaller than the depth of the
fractal so we need the depth of the
fractal in order to express the
distribution then with probability of at
least one minus Delta all the elements
of the gradient w are of magnitude which
looks like 1/2 minus V of J now if P of
J is close to 1/2 it means that when you
initialize all the gradient is basically
0 so you will not make any progress
starting to optimize from that point on
say the size of the network the depth of
the network your training this day the
depth of the network really Jay Jay yeah
what happens for J greater than than or
equal to so this is true for J equals n
minus 1 what happens so this is what
happens with J larger than n actually I
don't know is the network is not
realizable but is it a definite yeah I
missed it so J is just any number so
this is true for energy so it just need
to be larger than log of T so so J is
just a number that tells you that the
tells you how how the approximation
curve look like so if the approximation
curve is flat the above log T which is T
is the depth of the network and K square
case the weeds over Delta so if this is
just a number ok so suppose that you
want to take the depth to be 10 times n
okay any the depth of the refractive
okay so you you are saying I want larger
than the nth n times n so there is a
number and you decide on some weight
scale I don't know it will be 100 times
the time at sitar okay so you get this
number
rogue DK square over Delta which grows
just just over ethnic logarithmically
with the depths that you chose in the
width a future
okay so so you get some number so if J
now J you can take it to the intake
integer larger than this if J is greater
than this and the approximation curve is
such that P of J is close to 1/2 then
you will not be able to change it okay
now even I understand it this theorem
says that the gradients feet are small
but boy it doesn't mean that well you
are doing gradient descent and the
gradient is almost zero it's gonna be
explosion yeah it will not make any
progress in the beginning yeah
Ricky's probably really need PJ to be
extremely extreme yes it can be so you
can make it equals exactly to one half
and then you are at the local minimum at
the initialization almost truly what are
the norms of the weights that realizes
very small I mean it this the
and uses something about the
higher-order derivatives about the error
derivative higher-order derivatives like
second or third I don't think but this
is just for theoretician caching yeah
the previous theorem brief had J equals
to n plus 1 I think it's just an index
here it's a different meaning project I
say
okay here is you can you can actually
think about this pyramid J equals to the
smallest integer larger than this
so I think the interesting question is
in what what properties or the
instructions you need for this negative
result and what comment is of the
traction you need to the separation I
mean the first mystical creature is
example so for the probes for the
previous results for the strong depth
separation we just used the fractal is
by offering transformation and
contractive so mild assumptions this
theorem is for a very specific fractal
okay it's for the one-dimensional
control distribution okay so it's it's
much weaker than what we had before but
save this question so this will be the
conjecture that what we believe is that
this is not a you know what this is what
we managed to prove for what we believe
that the theorem is correct for not even
for fractals but for every distribution
so this is for the true population
gradients right so can you actually say
anything about the stochastic gradient
descent so we didn't work on it miss
Esther did though I guess you will get
some kind of random data dependent walk
and then it's less clear that you will
still be in a place where the gradients
are small or yeah I I agree
I mean basically ohad has a nice
examples of places when the gradient is
extremely small but some miracle happens
but but I think it's a strong evidence
that something very bad happens
now in general I think it's worse than
gradient descent so this is just an
empirical evaluation and what you see
here is that you see different curves
different approximation curves this is a
nice approximation curve and then it
becomes worse and worse and worse until
it's completely flattened and it goes up
so these curves will be the indices for
this graph okay
and what you see here is a is what
happens to learning depths v network on
the 2d contour set of depths v as a
function of how nice is approximation
curve and as expected you see that the
accuracy you can reach a very high
accuracy if the approximation curve is
nice but as approximation curve becomes
smaller and smaller you the performance
goes down now this is just one
two-dimensional problem so you still get
better than random you can actually
memorize things here okay but in higher
dimensions what we expect to see that is
that we will go to one half when the
approximation curve will not look like
it will not look nicely so this brings
me to the main conjecture that we want
to draw from the throttle distribution
is that what happens in in deep learning
is that you it's not a game of you must
go deeper and then you succeed and if
you go shallow then you cannot do
nothing so deep networks help going
deeper it helps you it really helps you
but only if the situation is not so bad
even with zero network
so this is just experiments with c4 then
and if you look at the effect of a depth
on unlearning then you see that that as
you go deeper and deeper performance
improves but not but that much it's not
it's not a matter of you know nothing
with cello and 85% with dip it's even
with a very shallow network you get to
70% and then you go to 80 and 83 84 85
but you can get 70% even with the show
this is with this wait the depth is the
colors and you think yes the shadow is
you think the shallowest just just
linear function but I think it does
increase if you go to complex task is
going imagenet so it's so this is yeah
but but is it random random guess and
isn't nothing with cello and is it
strong depth separation nothing with
cello
well I'm not sure but even if it's true
than with one hidden layer will you get
more than okay and there's a reason
there is a paper actually that recent
paper I don't remember and put it on the
slide but they did this experiment with
imagenet and show that even with the
shallow network and then you do great
the layer by layer training of of the
network so even with a relatively
shallow network you you get two
non-trivial results if it's not the case
then I argue that dip will not compute
also like the relative quantity for this
separation is the looks like improvement
at a loss compared to a random thing
that's that's probably true and this is
probably true if you look at the
gradient of of a nice loss function in
terms of success yeah
alright so when you shouldn't begin
enormous month respect to what not what
lush was it oh it was hinge looks like
okay so just just a tour last slide to
wrap up so fractal first fractal
distributions are very natural for
studying depth efficiency before
anything it is really very simple to to
prove that separation for distribution
we introduced the approximation curve
which quantifies how much going deeper
really helps you in terms of exclusivity
stronger depth separation means that the
approximation curve is flat and only at
the end it goes high and our conjecture
is that gradient based algorithms fail
when there is strong depth separation so
in other words deep is better
only when shallow is also good we didn't
prove the theorem we we show it in one
very particular case of the
one-dimensional contra distribution so
if we want to to talk a little bit more
in more detail about this conjecture and
direction for proving the conjecture so
we think something along this line let H
be all functions which cannot be
approximated by a shallow network then
we think that the following two things
are true first for each function if
within F so again a function which
cannot be approximated by a shallow
network then there is some distribution
that depends on F for which F realizes a
distribution
your loss was the best shallow Network
achieves a loss which is close to 1/2 so
this is one result for every function in
this class indeed there is a need for a
deep network and cello network will not
and the second argument is that for
every such DF so if you find this
distribution for which the best cello
network is close to 1/2 and then
gradient descent will fails to learn a
deep plan so for this particular
distribution we think that this is
roughly the way to tackle the conjecture
and we urge you to work on this
[Applause]
so what you mean is whenever we succeed
to make your network and we use
magnificent we should also try channel
network and yeah not as well but but but
you will not achieve random guest
performance the best of our knowledge
all the successes of deep networks
shallow network and now we can argue if
shallow is one hidden layer or two but
shallow networks achieves non-trivial
results
it's like making transform if I have an
arbitrary problem or Sheldon ever
guessed imagine like fitting the best
shelling Network and they're like
padding into the logics at the end it's
like they're part of a motion that's not
that's a break you can do it but but
then the question is will you be able to
to train the deep network and I argue
that you will not be able what's the
fracture limit fractal dimension
possible to calculate such a thing it's
a finite data type what's assumes that
it's a point distribution or that
innocent please take one front so you
can ask for these the depth to do you
know what's the minimum attractive
numbers that will shatter this I can say
a way to
you don't definitely okay maybe we'll
stick further questions offline get mr.
Pond so we're going to take a break now
[Applause]